Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This new learning-based method is capable
of generating new videos, creating lava from
water, enhancing your dance videos, adding
new players to a football game, and more.
This one will feel like it can do absolutely
anything!
For instance, have a look at these videos.
Believe it or not, some of these were generated
by an AI from this new paper.
Let’s try to find out together which ones
are real, and which are generated.
Now before we start, many of the results that
you will see here will be flawed, but I promise
that there will be some gems in there too.
This one doesn’t make too much sense.
One down.
Two, the bus appears to be changing length
from time to time.
Three, the bus pops out of existence.
Four…wait…this actually looks pretty good…until
we find out that someone is about to get rear-ended.
This leaves us with two examples.
Are they real, or are they fakes?
Now, please stop the video and let me know
in the comments.
So, this one is real footage.
Okay, what about this guy?
Well, get this…this one is actually one
of the generated ones.
Just this one was real.
And this is what this new technique is capable
of.
We give it a sample video, and it reimagines
variations of it.
Of course, the results are hit or miss, for
instance, here, people and cars just pop in
and out of existence, but if we try it on
the billiard balls.
Wow, now this is something.
Look at how well it preserved the specular
highlights, and also, the shadows move with
the balls in the synthetic variations too.
Once again, the results are generally quite
hit or miss, but if we look through a few
results, we often find some gems out there.
But this is nothing compared to what is to
come.
Let’s call this first feature video synthesis,
and we have 4 more really cool applications
with somewhat flawed, but sometimes amazing
results.
Now, check this out, here comes number two,
video analogies.
This makes it possible for us to mix two videos
that depict things that follow a similar logic.
For instance, here, only four of these sixteen
videos are real, the rest are all generated.
Now, here comes feature number three - time
retargeting.
For instance, we can lengthen or shorten videos.
Well, that sounds simple enough, no need for
an AI for that…but here is the key!
This does not mean just adding new frames
to the end of the video.
Look!
They are different.
Yes, the entirety of the video is getting
redesigned here.
We can use this to lengthen these videos without
really adding new content to it.
Absolutely amazing.
We can also use it to shorten a video.
Now, of course, once again, this doesn’t
mean that it just chops off the end of the
video.
No-no!
It means something much more challenging.
Look!
It makes sure that all of your killer moves
make it into the video, but, in a shorter
amount of time.
It makes the video tighter if you will.
Amazing feature number 4.
Sketch to video.
Here, we can take an input video, add a crude
drawing, and the video will follow this drawing.
The result is, of course, not perfect, but,
in return, this can handle many number to
number transitions.
And now, feature number five.
Video inpainting on steroids.
Previous techniques can help us delete part
of an image, or even a video, and generate
data in these holes that make sense given
their surroundings.
But this, this one does something way better!
Look, we can cut out different parts of a
video, and mark the missing region with a
color, and then, what happens?
Oh yes!
The blue regions will contain a player from
the blue team, the white region a player from
the white team, or, if we wish to get someone
out of the way, we can do that too.
Just mark them green.
Here, the white regions will be inpainted
with clouds, and the blues with birds.
Loving it.
But wait a second, we noted that there are
already good techniques out there for image
inpainting.
There are also good techniques for video time
retargeting.
So, what is so interesting here?
Well, two things.
One, here all of these things are being done
with just one technique.
Normally, we would need a collection of different
methods to perform all of these.
But here, just one AI.
Two, now hold on to your papers, and look
at this!
Whoa.
Previous techniques take forever to generate
these results.
144p means an extremely crude, pixelated image,
and even then, they take from hours…to,
my goodness.
Even days.
So, what about this new one?
It can generate much higher resolution images,
and, in a matter of minutes.
That is an incredible leap in just one paper.
Now, clearly, most of these results aren’t
perfect.
I would argue that they are not even close
to perfect.
But some of them already show a lot of promise.
And, as always, dear Fellow Scholars, do not
forget to apply the First Law of Papers.
Which says, do not look at where we are.
Look at where we will be two more papers down
the line.
And two more papers down the line, I am sure
that not two, but five, or maybe even six
out of these six videos will look significantly
more real.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!